high class c ont kiffé
liberté way
[Musique]
salut à tous et amour est dans cette
vidéo j'ai envie de vous raconter les
coulisses d'un documentaire que j'ai
adoré tourner qui s'appelle bike life
depuis la diffusion de bike lève sur
brut x beaucoup de choses ont changé
dans la vie de juniors celui qui m'ont
ouvert les portes de cet univers va pas
avec la vie c'est pas un qui me quitte
pas son qui dure un ou deux mois c'est
vraiment soit tu l'aies vraiment à 100%
soit chez les poids
[Musique]
après la diffusion du document ignore à
passer un casting pour un film et il a
obtenu le deuxième rôle secondaire dans
le film rodéo de lola qui vont qui est
sélectionné au festival de cannes c'est
prêcher par taper avec elle alors plaqué
le numéro vas-y bouge de la bouche tu
dis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nouvelle dans le gard
mike life on avait tourné en septembre
2020 et c'était pas de tout repos je
vous laisse découvrir les coulisses ça
fait plusieurs années que je filme dans
les quartiers et je croise souvent des
mecs avec des crosses si jamais posé la
question de vraiment de ce que faisait
ses motos cross en pleine ville je me
suis dit que ce docu ce serait
l'occasion de savoir qu'ils sont des
rencontres et de redonner la parole donc
j'ai commencé à faire plein de
recherches sur internet j'ai lu des
articles j'ai eu regarder des reportages
sur leurs deux urbain en fait ce qui
revenait le plus souvent c'est une
pratique dangereuse ces délinquants
c'est des mecs de cités qui font
n'importe quoi
on ne croit pas de la route on sait
qu'il ya quelqu'un de vaud qui lève et
fait des zigzags choix faut pas passer
devant lui tout ça on a on a des
manières de rouler tout voir d'un oeil
extérieur ça paraît dangereux c'est vrai
mais on sait ce qu'on fait toujours tout
les gens et dans toutes les zones on se
réunit tous les ans fait on fait de la
moto
on oublie les problèmes oubliez tout moi
en fait ces mecs passionnés de motocross
que j'avais envie d'entendre des débuts
en fait quand j'allais voir ces bikers
mon kiki parler de passion et c'est ce
qui fait que je voulais comprendre à
travers ce vote c'est comme ça que
j'entre en contact avec junior et quand
je le rencontre pour la première fois
ils me donnent rendez vous dans un fast
food à nanterre et c'est lui qui m'ouvre
les portes de l'univers de la veille
l'ex et pendant deux heures juniors il
fait des déclarations d'amour pour sa
moto vraiment là c'est comme si j'étais
avec ma meuf tout
c'est de l'amour clairement c'est de
l'amour
puisque pinto qui a la moto c'est mort
et grâce à junior en fait j'ai compris
que la becque live c'est beaucoup plus
qu'une aprem entre potes lui ce qu'ils
recherchent c'est à une vraie sensation
de liberté quand il est sur la moto il
me dit qu'il oublie tous ces problèmes
et sa fin avec live découvre entre amis
on est là on a la même passion fait des
rouges c'est ça la veille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait ce qui a été plus compliqué ce
qui a pris le plus de temps c'est de
gagner leur confiance parce que quand je
me suis présenté beaucoup m'ont dit que
ce sont être caricaturé dans les
reportages qui ont déjà été faits sur
les rodéos urbains et donc c'est un vrai
travail ce n'est pas simple en fait
d'arriver dans leur univers juste avec
ma caméra il fallait d'abord que je
montre patte blanche et que
en fait s'ils apprennent à me connaître
un faire confiance ce qui m'a frappé en
fait la première fois que des rencontres
est prêt dans les sous bois c'est qu'ils
viennent tous deux quartiers différents
de la région parisienne et que quand ils
sont ensemble sur la moto toutes les
frontières s'effacent erronée car au
nord on se retrouve là le week-end des
mecs de partout 9 en octobre 9 500 m3
donc après notre rencontre j'ai junior
au téléphone il me dit viens on sort en
bas road et je lui dis mais c'est quoi
une baroud en fait je comprends rien et
c'est le mot qu'utilisent les bacs
heures pour parler des sorties à moto
sur le périph parce qu'on appelle les
rodéos quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord j'avais peur de me casser la
gueule à moto et ensuite j'avais peur de
me retrouver embarqué dans une course
poursuite avec la police sur le périph
faut savoir que c'est une pratique qui
est interdite en ville c'est illégal et
ceux qui pratiquent le rodéo urbain
risque une peine de prison une amende ou
encore la confiscation de la moto
d'ailleurs junior n'est pas passé loin
de tout ça mais je vous en parlerai un
peu plus tard
[Musique]
tu t'en sors
la première fois que c'est sur la moto
c'est vrai que je suis pas super à
l'aise je suis pas stable du tout j'ai
un cas ce qui est trop grand pour ma
tête donc en fait du mois que dalle et
je pense que ça se voit sur les images
mes réglages par complètement vide qui
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
là ça fait plusieurs semaines que je
suis junior et ses potes et en fait je
vois rend compte que la plupart du temps
ils se retrouvent sur une piste de moto
école où ils sont à peu près tranquille
et c'est surtout la qui se retrouve en
fait pour faire de la moto ou alors
juste se poser en faute
[Musique]
près d'une heure à chaque fois que leurs
courbes et là tout le temps de nouveaux
trous dans son jean parce que et passe
son temps à se casser la gueule mais à
chaque fois il remonte sur sa moto il
repart derrière je vous raconte une
petite anecdote quand je tournais une
baroud avec junior et ses potes j ai
pris un peu d'avancé avec un de ses amis
et là je vois un mouvement de panique
tout le monde fait demi tour et je
commençais à être hyper inquiète parce
que je comprends que quelqu'un est tombé
et en arrivant je me rends compte que
ces juniors qui est à terre j'ai
vraiment peur mais là je le vois se
relever il remonte sur sa moto il repart
à toute vitesse j'ai déséquilibré cela
ça va emmener sur le trottoir et
mais jusqu'à vite
ça aulas attend
un truc de tordu la luxure tout
hollywood
on se retrouve sur la piste de moto
école on parle vite des accidents qui
arrivent à moto et juniors me parle du
bo ses potes qui devaient les rejoindre
le 6 octobre 2019 il me raconte son
histoire jour là on doit se rejoindre
pour se rassembler faire de la moto qui
fait toute une après midi et donc nous
on est et on est déjà là bas on fait là
bretons qui font la tente à bien ce pas
sortir la personne plus âgée pas de
casque
on sait qu quand je réalise ce
documentaire je me dis que je peux pas
raconter la bête live sans parler
d'histoire dit beau et c'est comme ça
que je rencontre pour la première fois
son frère
est beau quand il était tout petit
jeu-là menaient déjà par y faire du vélo
il vient d'élever deux roues en vélo
trocadéro au champ de mars et de la tour
eiffel la première fois que j'ai
rencontré à sarcelles c'est là où il
faut a grandi on se donne rendez vous
dans un local et à sa soeur ses frères
et à des amis il ya des membres du
collectif en fait ce jour là c'était un
moment très émouvant de ce doc parce que
il est en train d'organiser une marche
pour ibo il y avait tous les amis la
famille qui fabriquait des pancartes et
qui organisait le défilé
[Musique]
là on arrive au niveau du stop que tu
vois juste ici thibault il est devant
moi il ya un véhicule qui s'intercale
entre nous deux trois du coup au niveau
du stop on prend à droite et un becquet
d'entre eux vivront
celui qui me racontent l'histoire d'ibos
et samir un autre de ses potes ce jour
là ils se rendent ensemble sur la piste
de moto école le camion de police il
était là il fait un mouvement c'est
qu'un coup de volant et au moment où on
arrive ici je pense le camion de police
il a voulu bloquer la route tu vois
pourquoi que le cross et puis se passer
du coup il s'est décalé et l'arrivée
clairement sur notre voie tu vois
je suis arrivé à villiers-le-bel je le
voyais à manger
pas trace sur le visage un drap blanc
sur lui
cartonne
la luxueuse l'épreuve
[Musique]
ça a été très dur pour ça vient de
revenir sur les lieux
sur place avec plusieurs caméras de
vidéosurveillance et depuis deux ans en
fait la famille se bat pour avoir un
accès à ces vidéos pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé ce jour là quand je me
suis rendu à l'hommage pour ibos est
vrai que c'était très émouvant parce que
un moment j'ai vu arriver toutes les
motos d'un coup ça grondait de partout
et c'est vraiment là que j'ai ressenti
la solidarité qu'ils avaient entre eux
et j'ai vraiment compris que c'était une
famille en fait la famille de michael du
mal à rêver de la terre
[Musique]
pour toutes les familles quand on l'est
déjà on va priver
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez au début de cette vidéo que
c'était un tournage qui était très
mouvementée et tout pouvait arriver
après l'hommage les bakker qui de
sarcelles et là une course poursuite
s'engage avec les motards de police
sur la vidéo le back up vous voyez en
jaune ses juniors en fait il se rabat
sur le trottoir pour esquiver la police
il se fait arrêter
[Musique]
cette vidéo j'ai plus de nouvelles de
lui pendant 24 heures donc décidé de
contacter sa famille qui me dit qu'il
dans un commissariat à bobigny
30 heures n'ont pas provoqué au
baroud qu'on s'est dit on va faire allez
on va aller chercher la police mans
s'était organisée il y avait un départ
et ils nous attendaient dans la ville
d'à côté nous attendent et ils attendent
et ils ont lâché les motards sur nous il
me rend à son audience finalement il
s'en sort avec cinq mois de prison avec
sursis la profitation de sa moto et une
amende vas-y dans sa famille
[Musique]
j'ai quitté junior juste après son
jugement et aujourd'hui il va monter les
marches du palais des festivals à cannes
et je suis hyper contente qu'ils
puissent continuer à vivre sa passion
il a aussi réalisé le rêve dont il me
parlait tout le temps celui de faire de
la bécane aux etats unis c'est la houle
avec l'iphone et je vous mets quelques
extraits de son trépas miami
[Musique]
emma moche
fait de ma mère on est
marage tout
[Musique]
si cette vidéo vous a plu était pas à me
faire des retours en commentaire je
délirais et si vous voulez voir bike
live c'est disponible sur brut x moi je
vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]